my name is Don Tapscott and I'm on a
council called informed society it's an
issue that we're addressing it's that
because of the new media the internet
social networking and so on and also at
the end of the industrial age its media
radio television broadcasting the huge
change is taking place in how inform
ourselves as society the old media was
one too many it was one way it was
controllable and people out there
recipient's the readers that viewers the
listeners were past that they were not
yet but the new media all of that is
turned on its head its interactive it's
collaborative it's highly distributed
and it has this awesome neutrality
soaked how do we stay informed as a
society in this kind of world how do we
ensure that this good journalism
investigative journalism the journalists
get paid how do we prevent a
balkanization of society where wrong
these little self-reinforcing echo
chambers and all we get is our own point
of view and the purpose of information
perhaps us to give us comfort rather
than to inform us so what we've ended up
doing is creating a memo to the leaders
of the world about how to address this
problem and we're arguing that yes this
is a time of great change of great
volatility even of unrest but what you
need to do is take steps to open up the
internet to open up access to
information how greater transparency and
to ensure that people can use these
tools to collaborate with us and that
the worst thing you can do is to try and
curtail these of the technology or shut
down the internet is some some leaders
have done in some countries you know
what all of this is good it's good for
citizens to be informed participated
helps in the development of wealth
health care better protection of the
environment of creating better education
and the transformation of every
institution so if you're a world leader
embrace the new media and help
buildings form societies and good media
sensation